[Música]
es que en los últimos cinco años en
américa latina ha habido por lo menos 20
protestas ciudadanas de gran magnitud
fuertemente reprimidas por las
autoridades algunas duraron unos varios
meses como en venezuela- en 2017
banchile a finales de 2019 colombia ese
mismo año y también de nuevo en el año
2021 el llamado estallido social también
de colombia una investigación liderada
por una decena de medios regionales
junto al centro de latinoamericano de
investigación periodística constatan que
a medida que ha crecido la protesta
social también se ha fortalecido el
negocio de las armas no letales en 8
países estas armas causaron la muerte de
al menos 33 personas y causaron heridas
de gravedad en otras 170 además de dejar
una estela de los miles de lesiones
leves y traumas sicológicos el estudio
también denuncia que aunque en muchos
países escasean los recursos públicos
para responder a las víctimas el dinero
si alcanza para comprar estas armas
destinadas al control de las masas y la
represión de las protestas en 8 países
de la región se gastaron al menos
112 millones de dólares en equipos
antimotines y armas no letales en el
último lustro vamos a saludar entonces a
teresa ronderos ella es periodista y
directora del centro latinoamericano de
investigación periodística gracias a
maría tereza por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 muy buen
día y le pregunto entonces cuáles son
estas armas no letales en las que
invierten los países de nuestra región
mira encontramos que invierten sobre
todo en todo tipo de balines de goma
balines de plomo vale pero que son como
de cacería que no son letales y también
en gases lacrimógenos muchísimo y todo
tipo de gases pimienta todo tipo de
aerosoles que
afectan
digamos inmediatamente la posibilidad de
la gente de estar en una manifestación
también hay en algunos casos armas más
complicadas como la ve no me en colombia
que es un arma que al tiempo produce luz
aturde con mucho ruido y además dispara
gases entonces en todo tipo de
armas que producen ruido asustar o
producen gases claro maria thereza pero
también digamos que estas armas no
letales y se utilizan sin saber cómo
hacerlo correctamente pudieran y pueden
y han causado además la muerte de varias
personas porque además de comprarlas no
se enfoca en los gobiernos en hacer una
debida instrucciones del uso de estos
equipos antimotines de los estados
si una de las cosas que nosotros
encontramos es que hay todo un sistema
que funciona mal porque claro estas
armas se necesitarían y son una avance
de la humanidad frente antes que
reprimían en manifestaciones o protestas
con armas letales o con revólveres o con
fusiles que eso pues obviamente queremos
dejarlo atrás pero estas armas que si
bien son muy positivas
no se están comprando bien no se compran
debidamente para lo que se necesitan
exactamente hay muchísima poco rigor
mucha mucha flexibilidad en cómo se
compran cómo se usan como tú dices a las
personas que las están usando en
generalmente es la fuerza pública no les
dan el entrenamiento debido pero tampoco
les dan la dotación debida para el tipo
de fuerza que tienen que enfrentar o
para el tipo de circunstancia estas
armas pueden actuar distinto
que a nivel del mar pueden actuar
distinto en callejones cerrados que en
sitios abiertos
entonces nos falta muchísimo para
garantizar que realmente estas armas
sirvan para proteger la protesta
ciudadano claro maría tereza y también
en su investigación les quiero preguntar
cuáles son los países más peligrosos a
la hora de protestar y también cuáles
son los países que más invierten en este
tipo de armamentos habló también de
peligroso porque en algunos vídeos y en
algunas situaciones se ve más allá de la
fuerza pública por tratar de contener
una protesta que se pudiera volver
violenta en algún punto se ve como si
fuera una lucha personal contra los
manifestantes
claro que es todo lo contrario de lo que
estas armas buscan o estas armas buscan
separar a la fuerza pública de los
manifestantes por si llega a haber gente
violenta que lo también 'sine ese sea
proteger a estos agentes pero esto no es
lo que sucede termina como usted dice en
un cuerpo a cuerpo cuáles son los países
más peligrosos pues definitivamente los
países donde todavía se siguen usando
armas letales son los más peligrosos
vimos el caso de venezuela el caso a
nicaragua aunque no profundizamos en él
la prensa ha documentado múltiples y las
organizaciones de derechos humanos
cantidades de muertos en contexto de
protesta en muertos por armas letales
pero también las armas no letales han
causado muchísimas víctimas sobre todo
en colombia y en chile fueron los dos
países donde armas no letales causaron
grandes daños en los países que más
gastan en las compras de armas no
letales nosotros hasta donde pudimos
documentar porque este es un sector muy
poco y es muy difícil acceder a toda la
información
pero entre los que más gastaron está por
supuesto brasil que es el más grande
enseguida colombia después chile y
después
argentina y por último méxico
maría teresa también le quiero preguntar
por la responsabilidad del estado en
todo esto sobre todo para las víctimas
se les ha dado un tipo de respuesta a un
tipo de reparación también
tratando el tema de esta un arma no
letal también que es muy usada que es
estas pistolas de gases lacrimógenos que
también las han disparado directamente
hacia la cara o hacia el miembro del
cuerpo de una persona que pueden causar
graves heridas incluso perder un ojo
como le hemos visto en chile en
venezuela
sí claro nosotros documentamos muchos
casos incluso entrevistamos a los
testigos con nombre y apellido de las
personas que perdieron sus ojos el caso
más famoso y el caso de la hoy senadora
cambio la cantidad en chile
es estos estos estos personas que han
sufrido y enfrentan una generalmente una
desidia del estado en algunos casos en
brasil por ejemplo ha habido
digámosle les han dado indemnizaciones
en también en bolivia vimos algunos
casos donde hubo indemnizaciones pero en
general los dejan sin nada no hay plata
para ayudarlos como lo constatamos en
guatemala por ejemplo en ecuador y la
justicia va muy lenta en muchos casos
han agarrado al anti gamos a la policía
que disparó mal del arma que disparó a
la cara pero estar con casa por cárcel o
en algunos casos ni siquiera han
investigado o han dado con quién fue el
responsable de que alguien se quedara
sin o no
claro se quedan impunes y también en
muchos casos también es difícil digamos
determinar el contexto de cómo ocurrió
todo porque pues a menos que tengan una
cámara evidentemente para para hacer lo
que no es el caso de muchos de nuestros
países pero finalmente quiero
preguntarle más cereza quiénes son los
principales proveedores de estas armas
digamos de estos países de nuestra
región a quien se las compras
pues estos países se las compran a
tres grandes proveedores que nosotros
encontramos dos compañías americanas que
se llaman non non liza y la otra se
llama combined systems que a su vez son
parte de conglomerados más grandes y una
gran proveedora sobre todo para
suramérica esconder que es una empresa
brasilera ellas son las grandes
proveedores pero lo que encontramos
preocupante es que hay un montón de
intermediarios en casi todos los países
encontramos una gama de intermediarios
muchos con pasados bastante complicados
en un mercado bastante oscuro que muchas
veces no le cumplen al estado y con todo
eso siguen teniendo contratos en otros
casos son personas con con trayectorias
bastante cuestionables comunica uno de
los casos en argentina que había una
persona dueña de una de estas empresas
fue condenado por haber sido torturador
en la época de la dictadura militar
entonces es un mercado todavía sumamente
oscuro y sumamente poco transparente lo
que no debería
pues obviamente porque esto está
afectando a miles sino millones de
personas cuando salen a protestar
debería ser un mercado super
transparente